[Música]
le pusieron precio a mi cabeza
en algunos de esos mensajes me
amenazaban con secuestrarme
matarme y desmembrarme
este antiguo Coronel de la policía
Saudita se encuentra refugiado en
Londres tras presentar su dimisión pidió
asilo político en el Reino Unido ravic
alenazi publica videos en tiktok que
suelen alcanzar más de un millón de
vistas Poco después de su llegada a la
capital inglesa anunció su deserción
dice vivir atemorizado porque cuentas
sauditas le pusieron precio a su cabeza
en Twitter
soy el coronel ravi jalenesi de la
agencia de seguridad nacional Este es mi
documento de identidad
anunció mi deserción del régimen Saudita
frecuentemente transmite videos en
directo en tiktok en los que aborda
temas como las presuntas torturas en las
cárceles sauditas también pide que el
príncipe heredero Mohamed Bin salman sea
juzgado por crímenes de guerra un día
empezó un directo desde un restaurante
entre las 5000 personas que estaban
siguiendo la transmisión en vivo una
cuenta de Twitter escribió
estoy viendo este directo Denme unos
minutos y haré que lo echen del
restaurante y unos minutos después
perdón pero no puede hacer ese tipo de
comentarios en tiktok hemos recibido
quejas tendrá que dejar de transmitir
Mientras esté en este restaurante
por ahora me despido de ustedes
desde entonces la cuenta bajo el nombre
de insatam comenzó a rastrear a ravio
alenzi publicó imágenes del interior de
su residencia junto con un aviso de
búsqueda recompensa
mil reales para Quien tenga información
sobre este individuo alquila un
apartamento en Londres probablemente en
la zona de Kensington tras este anuncio
sus seguidores sugirieron las posibles
ubicaciones de su objetivo los
cibernautas lograron encontrar a Rabbit
alenzi y revelaron la dirección de su
hotel en Twitter
cambio de domicilio con regularidad
Solo cuando es necesario para ir a hacer
compras o a comer
sigue recibiendo cientos de amenazas no
te librarás tan fácilmente voy a ir a
buscarte a Londres pero también recibe
cientos de comentarios que elogian al
príncipe heredero mohamedman entonces
quién está detrás de la cuenta de
insatán esta fue eliminada poco después
de que varios artículos fueron
publicados en la prensa internacional
como el nuestro en Front 24.com en
francés
así se veía su cuenta su foto de perfil
era una imagen de archivo en su
biografía se describía como Saudita por
identidad y por pasión al lado de su
dirección de correo electrónico indicaba
que se le podía escribir para cualquier
información sobre la oposición Saudita
abdulá aloud defiende a los opositores
sauditas exiliados en Estados Unidos
para él esta cacería la organiza un
ejército de troles sauditas
sus misiones pueden resumirse así
primero promover la agenda del Estado
mejorar la imagen de las figuras
políticas especialmente la de Mohamed
benzalman
segundo difundir el mensaje de que el
pueblo Saudita en todos sus niveles
apoya y Ama al régimen
tercero persiguen y enjuician a
cualquiera que se atreva a criticar al
régimen Saudita
mientras recibe respuesta a su solicitud
de asilo ravij alenzi ha pedido la
protección de la policía de Londres
[Música]
una multitud arroja objetos contra una
mezquita en la ciudad de badodara en el
estado de guyara oeste de India esta
escena fue grabada durante el festival
hindú derrama navami en el que se
celebra el nacimiento del dios rama
cuchara es uno de los seis estados
indios donde los nacionalistas hindúes
han atacado mezquitas y musulmanes
anteriormente
ondean sus banderas sus ofensas
lanzan piedras
y gritan frases provocadoras como
Qué significa en hindi Gloria al dios
rama
[Aplausos]
la comunidad musulmana se vio
profundamente afectada por los violentos
disturbios de 2002 en los cuales casi
dos mil musulmanes fueron asesinados en
represalias por la muerte de unos 50
peregrinos hindúes
[Música]
nuestro observador es abogado y defensor
de los musulmanes en el estado de
guyarat
la multitud que participaba en el
festival lanzó piedras contra la
comunidad musulmana los dos grupos se
enfrentaron
después de esto uno de los organizadores
del festival hizo declaraciones de odio
y provocó a la policía a la comunidad
musulmana ya toda la comunidad de badora
desafortunadamente lo que ocurrió fue
que la policía sólo tomó medidas contra
los musulmanes
la policía también detuvo a unas cinco
mujeres ellas no estaban entre la
multitud y no habían lanzado piedras
desde hace cuatro o cinco años la
celebración del festival de Rama está
dirigida contra la comunidad musulmana
desde que narendra modi asumió el cargo
de Primer Ministro en 2014 el partido
nacionalista hindú el bjp está en el
poder en India
llegamos al final de este episodio de
Los observadores si quieren contactar a
nuestro equipo todos nuestros contactos
aparecen aquí en pantalla envíenos sus
fotos y videos y tal vez el próximo
observador de France 24 sea uno de
ustedes hasta la próxima semana